Veo unos jóvenes desde una perspectiva
que se fija en las ventajas que aportan al sistema educativo.
¿Se unirán a mí para cambiar la etiqueta que les define
de jóvenes "en riesgo" a jóvenes "promesas"?
(Aplausos)
¿Y cómo sé que estos jóvenes
tienen el potencial y prometen?
Lo sé porque soy uno de ellos.
Saben, me crié en un barrio céntrico en pobreza extrema
sin padre...
me abandonó antes de nacer.
Recibíamos ayuda del estado,
a veces no teníamos un hogar y muchas veces qué comer.
Antes de cumplir los 15 años
ya pasé por la prisión juvenil tres veces por tres delitos
y mi mejor amigo había muerto.
Al poco tiempo,
dispararon a mi tío en mi presencia
y había visto, mientras esperaba a la ambulancia
más de una hora en la calle,
cómo se desangraba.
Había perdido la fe y la esperanza en el mundo
y había renunciado al sistema porque el sistema me había abandonado.
No tenía nada que ofrecer
y nadie tenía nada que ofrecerme.
Era fatalista.
Estaba seguro de que no iba a cumplir los 18 años.
El motivo por el que sigo aquí
es una profesora a quien le importé,
que se acercó y logró llegar a mí.
Esta profesora,
la señora Russ,
era ese tipo de profesora que siempre se metía en tus asuntos.
(Risas)
Era este tipo de profesora
que decía: "Víctor, estoy aquí tan pronto como estés dispuesto".
(Risas)
Pero no lo estaba.
Y ella entendía algo básico sobre los jóvenes como yo:
éramos como ostras.
Solo íbamos a abrirnos cuando estuviéramos listos,
y si no estás allí para nosotros cuando te necesitamos,
volveremos a cerrarnos.
La señora Russ estaba a mi lado.
No tuvimos un choque cultural;
respetaba a mi comunidad, a mi gente, a mi familia.
Le conté la historia de mi tío Rubén.
Me llevaba con él a trabajar porque sabía que estaba en bancarrota
y me hacía falta el dinero.
Recolectaba botellas vacías.
A las cuatro de la mañana en un día de cole
ya estábamos tirando las botellas en la parte de atrás de la furgoneta
y como el cristal se rompía
tenía cortes en las manos y en los brazos
y sangre en los zapatos y los pantalones.
Estaba aterrado y dolorido y me hubiera gustado dejar de trabajar.
Y mi tío me miraba a los ojos y me decía:
"Hijo mío,
nos estamos buscando la vida".
Intentamos buscarnos una vida mejor,
intentamos hacer algo con nada".
La señora Russ me escuchó,
me invitó a compartirlo en clase y me decía:
"Víctor, este es tu punto fuerte.
Este es tu potencial:
tu familia, tu cultura, tu comunidad, que te enseñaron la ética del trabajo
y hay que usarla para sacar de ello fuerzas para tus resultados académicos,
para que puedas devolver este poder a tu comunidad".
Con la ayuda de la señora Russ
empecé a volver a la escuela.
Incluso aprobé las asignaturas a tiempo
y me gradué junto con mis compañeros.
(Aplausos)
Pero la señora Russ me dijo justo antes de la graduación:
"Víctor estoy muy orgullosa de ti.
Sabía que podías hacerlo.
Es la hora de ir a la universidad".
(Risas)
¿En la uni? ¿Yo?
¿Qué se habrá fumado que piensa que iré a la uni?
Lo intenté, y con su ayuda y la de los mentores a los que me recomendó,
me admitieron en la uni con una carta que decía:
"Estás admitido pero provisional".
¿Cómo que provisional?
Ya estaba con la provisional, ¿esto no cuenta?
(Risas)
Era un término académico, no penal.
¿Pero qué hacen los profesores como la señora Russ para lograr
ayudar a jóvenes como los que yo estudio?
Sugiero tres estrategias.
La primera:
terminemos con la opinión estándar sobre ellos en educación:
"Esta gente viene de una cultura llena de violencia y pobreza.
Esta gente está en riesgo, son vagos.
Esta gente son recipientes vacíos que no podemos enriquecer con conocimiento.
Tienen problemas,
pero nosotros tenemos la solución".
Número dos:
valoremos las historias y los contextos que estos jóvenes aportan al aula.
Estas historias de cómo han superado obstáculos imposibles son muy poderosas
y sé que conocen algunas de ellas.
Estas historias y estas experiencias
ya se caracterizan por valor, fuerza de carácter y fuerza,
así que ayudemos a estos jóvenes a refinar estas historias.
Ayudémosles a estar orgullosos de sí mismos.
Digámosles que nuestro sistema educativo acoge a sus familias, a su cultura,
a su comunidad
y las capacidades que han desarrollado para sobrevivir.
Y, desde luego, la tercera estrategia y la más importante:
los recursos.
Hay que proveer a estos jóvenes los recursos adecuados.
La valentía sola no vale.
Pueden estar allí sentados y repetirme:
"Toma el control de tu vida".
Pero ¡si nada más nacer la vida me controla a mí!
(Risas)
¿Cómo voy a tomar el control?
(Aplausos)
Falta formación profesional, tutorías, asesoramiento,
enseñar a estos jóvenes a aprender de sus errores
en lugar de criminalizarlos
y sacarlos de clase como a un animal.
¿Qué les parece esto?
Propongo la reinstauración de la rehabilitación
a través de la reconciliación en cada escuela estadounidense.
(Aplausos)
Así que salimos a poner esto en práctica en la comunidad de Watts en Los Ángeles
con 40 jóvenes que fueron expulsados.
William era uno de ellos.
William era ese tipo de joven al que tachaban de todo:
fracasado, pandillero,
criminal.
Cuando lo conocimos estaba muy a la defensiva.
Pero recordé las palabras de la señora Russ:
"Oye, yo estoy aquí tan pronto como estés dispuesto".
(Risas)
Así que, con el tiempo,
con el tiempo empezó a abrirse.
Y me acuerdo el día que hizo la transición.
Estábamos con un grupo numeroso
y una chica del programa empezó a llorar
mientras nos contaba su historia
sobre la muerte de su padre
y cómo al día siguiente tuvo que ver su cadáver en el periódico.
Ella lloraba y yo no sabía qué hacer,
así que le di un poco de intimidad
pero William ya no aguantó más.
Pegó un puñetazo en el pupitre y dijo:
"Oye, todo el mundo, ¡abrazo en grupo, abrazo en grupo!"
(Aplausos)
Las lágrimas y el dolor de esta joven se convirtieron en alegría y risa
porque entendió que no estaba sola
mientras que William aprendió que él podía tener un propósito en la vida,
el de curar el alma de la gente de su comunidad.
Nos contó su historia.
Cambiamos su historia
de una donde él era una victima a otra donde era un superviviente
que superó los infortunios.
Le dimos mucho peso a esta historia.
William llegó a terminar la secundaria,
y se recibió de guardia de seguridad
y ahora trabaja de eso en una escuela del barrio.
(Aplausos)
El mantra de la señora Russ,
su mantra siempre ha sido:
"Cuando enseñas al corazón, la mente lo sigue".
El gran escritor Khalil Gibran dijo:
Del sufrimiento han surgido las almas más fuertes,
y los carácteres más fuertes están plagados de cicatrices".
Creo que a esta revolución en el aula de la que estamos hablando
necesitamos invitar a las almas de estos jóvenes con quienes trabajamos,
y una vez que puedan pulir,
identificar su valor, su fuerza y el verdadero carácter
que ya desarrollaron,
su desempeño académico mejorará.
Creamos en los jóvenes.
Ofrezcámosles los recursos adecuados.
Les diré que hizo mi profe por mí.
Creyó tanto en mí
que me engañó y me hizo creer en mí mismo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)